da habe ich gleich die habe ich gleich
und ist immer drin stehen
ja das wird keine typische folge heute
arm vosslohs die leute man löscht das
noch fünf tage mit ihr bock habt euch
zum beispiel dieses t shirt zu können
dann checkt auf jeden fall den ersten
ligen der beschreibung april
super dass ich ganz vorne anfang war
aufnahme fand am 27.11 abends statt das
waren so ein tag und ich war den ganzen
wochenende also vor allem mittwoch ist
sonntag in berlin und alle die mich
kennen wissen dass ich nicht in berlin
wohne das heißt ich war nur mit meinem
laptop und hatte nicht so wirklich
gescheites aufnahme equipment ich musste
an diesem tag aber auch in berlin seien
weil ich das sonntagmorgen noch einen
termin hat einen sehr wichtigen da
musste ich einfach sein denn es war
keine freizeit entscheidung und deswegen
musste ich dann abends auf meinem laptop
war auf den ball hier alle die
normalerweise auf pc aufnehmen und an
mal auf dem laptop aufgenommen am wissen
dass es irgendwie nicht das gleiche ist
deutlich deutlich deutlich schwieriger
auf dem laptop auf zunehmendem ausfällt
sich irgendwie anders zu tasten sind
ganz ganz ganz anders und das ist auch
mit ein grund dafür dass gestorben bin
aber erst und das ganze geworden ich
hatte so die 45 nächte vor der aufnahme
ist so wenig geschlafen und dieses ganze
aufnahme chaos zusammen mit der
aufregung die trotzdem dabei war hat
dazu geführt dass ich erstmal effekt
habe die aufnahme zu stellen
ifa war oft auch zu starten ich geholt
und dann mittendrin ist alles in trance
auch toms aufnahmen und verlegt doch als
erste folge check die unbedingt ab
mitten in der folge max oder soll ich
glaub ich hab sie aufgestanden ist
eine probeaufnahme der hektik ist dort
ja ok alles klar machen wir zu dir gott
stehe ich muss kurz sie auch beim
starten ich tipp genau jetzt der nächste
pause minecraft gehe raus gehen ubs
zurück auf aufnahme gehe wieder in
minecraft rein was passiert darum ist
weg dort ist jedoch weiter aus ich bin
das genau da setzt meine aufnahme ein
und das passiert natürlich im moment ich
drehe mich um sie scheiße dom ist nicht
da und was passiert mir
selbstverständlich als nächstes vom
orders namen oder dem smc expert stehe
ich es auch dabei und es entstehen
emstek wieso bist du ich hab so viel
stil
die explosion hätte mir ein anliegen das
ganze chaos schon los die hat nicht
selbstverständlich in dem moment auch
schon gesehen und ich bin einfach nur
gerannt gerannt gerannt und mein leben
ich musste die gute wahl wie konzert
nicht treffen
das ging gar nicht über alle total
aufgeregt dass es wirklich so ein chaos
leute wer selbst nicht mehr wahr oder
bei war kann das nicht einschätzen und
man ist bei war so unfassbar aufgeregt
also was mache ich natürlich im moment
innerhalb der fläche da alles scheiße fc
experten stehen sind intermedia mein
team partner ist in reichweite was macht
man da was das einzig sinnvolle weg
laufen westen lässt wissen
ich glaub wissen
eine koordinate 570 15 75 15
ja ich laufen excel sind direkt hinter
mir direkt das problem ist so dass es
mit dem weg laufen nicht so gut
funktioniert hat heute alles klar
komm mal zu 600 wir das jetzt hab ich
gleich die hab ich gleich fleisch gegen
sex mit mir dann immer näher kam wusste
ich okay ich komme auf eine option
ich musste da machen die tage gültig
solange bisschen schnell rennen kann ein
klatschen nicht von hinten weg und das
dachte ich mir es einfach so scheiße
komm mach mint turnaround und dann ist
das hier passiert wirklich einig
nein ich bin schockiert
und ja die große frage bei dem ganzen es
leute wie konnte das passieren zwei
nämlich im wesentlichen drei faktoren
ich kann eben schon mal so ein bisschen
an gelassen hat und zwar viel viel viel
viel viel zu wenig ich habe einfach
diese doppelbelastung aus studium und
youtube parallel nummer zwei das
equipment ich war ein moment in berlin
und ich muss in berlin sein wie gesagt
das heißt ich konnte einfach nur mit
meinem laptop auf nämlich in meinem pc
zu hause durch selbstverständlich viel
besser spiele untermerzbach ließ nummer
drei die aufregung ich kann einfach mit
dieser aufregung im mini zu spielen und
wenn dann natürlich auf einmal team und
steht ihr euch verfolgen dann setzt
natürlich auch die panik also doch das
klingt weist das computerspiel aber es
ist einfach so aber letzten endes macht
es mich persönlich trauriger ziehen ware
ausgeschieden bin
ich hatte ganz gerne mal gesehen wie das
ist so ein projekt länger als eine folge
da zu sein und den tag wird auch
garantiert kommen ist kann es sein dass
man zweifel an der ersten folge
ausschaltet das habe ich traurig bin es
einfach weil sich einige von euch sich
darauf gefreut haben dass sie die
projekte weit komme und für diese leute
die ich damit so ein bisschen enttäuscht
aber auch wenn enttäuscht folgen über
teams im kontext für diese leute tut mir
leid er will es mir auch leid tut ist
mein team partner doch der ist jetzt die
ganze sache alleine bestreiten warum
einfach weil ich zu viel zu tun hatte in
diesem moment weil ich zu chaotisch war
zu aufgeregt waren aber heute
abschließend bisschen was das leben geht
weiter klar aus es ist schade es ist
echt schade gerade für doktor lisa
kleidung für euch aber live person und
dann alle youtuber da draußen